good morning believe nation today's
message is enhanced your perception and
intelligence overuse that guru
amigo effort has to be incisive in the
sense it should be focused calibrated
symbol if you make effort it's foolish
effort isn't it just labor is not going
to get you somewhere right kind of
action the right timing right place all
this is important isn't it
so for all these things to happen you
need perception and intelligence so
that's all you must do in your life
constantly looking for ways to enhance
your perception and your intelligence
the rest will anyway happen this is one
thing that unfortunately humanity is not
doing they're trying to become capable
of something do not try to become
capable of something just enhance your
perception and intelligence I think that
hard-working Hustle is your ticket in I
think that's just getting you to the
table right for anybody who wants to
have any level of success you have to
you have to work hard you got to hustle
you got to grind it out you got to put
in the work right to think that you can
work smart and not put in the hustle and
rise anywhere close to the top or
achieve anywhere close to your full
potential you're fooling yourself you've
got to be able to put in the hustle but
to his point you have to put in the
hustle in the right spots you got to use
your intelligence and perception to make
sure you're doing the right things
because a lot of times we put in the
work but we're not putting in the work
in the right areas and so we don't get
the success that we're looking at and
this was me in my first business right I
was grinding I was hustling I was
putting in every waking hour all my
money everything and
was sucking and not getting results and
not achieve what I wanted to do for the
first time in my life and struggling on
three hundred dollars a month and eating
beans for lunch every day it wasn't for
lack of working hard it was because I
didn't have the perception or
intelligence to put it in the right area
and I feel like to improve your
perception improve your intelligence is
two ways to do it the first is just by
experience by practicing by trying you
try something you see if it works or not
and not enough people not enough
entrepreneurs are trying enough new
things to get that experience you do the
same thing over and over and over and
over again and it's not working right
what's the definition of insanity doing
the same thing over and over again
expecting different results
you have to try to get experience to see
what will work or not as a quick
personal example Jason my videographer
here tried out the new sushi place
downstairs one week and he loved it and
now every week you can't wait to come
and have sushi he was late coming today
because it's picking up his sushi but he
loves the sushi so much and he's learned
from that today he went out and he tried
some kettle cooked dill pickle chips
that he hated and he threw away half the
bag and so he's learned from that right
and so he knows now he's going to get
the sushi he's not going to get the
kettle cooked chips and by trying with
those different things he's grown and
got a better understanding of how to
feed and fuel his body you got to do the
same thing for your business right
you're trying different things you're
seeing what works sometimes it'll work
sometimes it won't but by trying those
different things by taking an action it
improves your perception and
intelligence on what will and will not
work the second thing is adding just
more awareness because you don't have
all the ideas yourself this is my
biggest struggle starting up I thought I
had all the ideas I thought I'd looking
with everything myself and it wasn't
until I started modeling success and
looking to bill gates that turned my
software company around that was my
story and now I love my own youtube
channel I made it selfishly for me a lot
of these videos because I want to
surround myself people who have done a
lot more to see how they see the world
to help shift my mindset to learn from
people who've done way more than I have
maybe ever will and you know have some
of those influences rub off on me
because I don't know personally people
who've done
amazing great things on that level and
so I feel like hanging around my channel
I get to soak up a little bit of that
wisdom and that makes me a little bit
stronger more perceptive more
intelligent every day that helps me
change my mindset and make better
decisions so take action and model
success and surround yourself with an
environment that forces you to become
the best version of yourself
so the question of the day today is I'm
curious what the most recent experiment
is that you ran in your business whether
it worked out or not what did you try
recently try to help you grow crucified
out leaving the comments below and I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events beso okay